déjà on va pas se mentir une star durant
de booba qui vient sur un plateau et qui
n'a aucune exigence sur les invités ça
n'existe pas lui on lui a dit voilà il y
aura une sorcière il y aura jean messia
il y aura un membre du red hill à rien
déjà sur le papier
en vrai il ya plein de stars turdine on
laisse alors j'ai pas envie de ressasser
le ca est au barça il a accepté donc à
permettre d'échanger le débat avec vous
deuxièmement vous avoir fait découvrir
il acceptait deuxièmement il y avait une
mécanique c'était la mécanique de buzzer
juste avant il a besoin une sorcière qui
restait trente secondes ça n'a choqué
personne vous ça doit choquer tout le
monde on sait pas pourquoi par une rente
dixièmement pardon vous avez accueilli
booba qui est quand même une grande star
que vous vouliez ou non
mercialys en défendant sa logique bah si
c'est une énorme star est en classe 3 et
venir et en démêlant droit de le dire
sur un plateau pour dire qu'on aimait un
désaccord avec la patrie de ramener le
garrido le venezuela on est d'accord
mais accueillir à quand des martyrs ont
dit en sous-entendant que sa musique
c'est de la merde parce que j'ai pas dit
ça j'ai dit que gbp a ensuite fait pas
regarder écouter
connaissez-vous bah oui oui mais bien
humainement je sais pas mais j'aime pas
ça moi je sois honnête
moi je n'aime pas badie le mais je te
connais pas et humainement donc je peux
pas t'aider je peux pas dire si je
t'aime ou papa genre c'est normal qu'on
arrive comme ça moi vous arriver sur nos
côtes et vous dites je sais pas toi mais
j'aime pas tes émissions là mais le
maquillage braquage il devrait pas les
martyrs très franchement monsieur jouez
pas les martyrs de bayrou un traitement
particulier je vous laisse parler
arrivé qu un ego démesuré pour faire du
buzz elle fracassée et ben ils vous à
virey et moi je lui dis il a bien fait
de vous virer alors les gens les gens
les gens qui qui qui vote extrême droite
bien entendu il faut leur parler il faut
convaincre mais vous là vous êtes arrivé
soit les épaules de chacun vote pour
qu'ils veulent c'est exactement ce que
dit on n'est pas des donneurs de leçons
et ses juges père ça justement gg oui
dis pas oui aux gens qui votent
extrêmement qu'il faut leur parler mais
avoue il a bien fait vous virer celle
que vous étiez arrivé spécifiquement
pour faire une séquence avec lui lui
taper dessus en temps comme vous n'avez
même pas dit je vous aime en tant
qu'homme je ne sais pas si je vous aime
entendre aux navires est que le buzzer
il a bien fait vous vous étiez vous
étiez journaliste je crois oui je sais
vous pourrez vous poursuivez la pelure
le pluralisme que vous avez pratiqué
derrière facebook poursuivent et ici
mais d'accord hier j'ai particulièrement
peu apprécié votre intervention parce
que normalement c'est un débat c'est pas
moi qui ai demandé à venir est celui qui
avait à l'ego démesuré ce n'était
certainement pas moi c'était le c'était
le pingouin en survêtement j'avais en
face de moi demain 6 rue et 6 6 3 lire
ce que j'ai le droit de dire ce que je
veux et si ça vous plaît pas c'est
pareil booba c'est sympa mais c'est pas
parce que ce mec pèse 185 millions
d'euros qu'il faut ça plate rs carapater
devant lui c'est sa valeur ces
divergences et l invité dans l'émission
effet très peu d'émissions où le on lui
on lui expliquer les règles on a dit
voilà il ya une règle bien buzzer si tu
n'as plus envie de débattre tu peux buzz
et les moindres mais moi mon avis lui ce
alors à l'âge et à la limite c'est plus
moi le responsable que lui il faut que
l'été l'espagne les faut que vos
téléspectateurs sinon je suis fixé la
règle que moi j'ai été appelé par vos
équipes pour venir débattre alors que
vous allez vous dit qu'il a accepté le
principe du débat puisse a été formel
mais l'axé bien accepté que je viens 45
secondes pour me dire j'ai pas envie de
débattre 4ième